what are these things these things are
called you might see on there it's
called a um everyone pronounce it
differently I call it a clinometer uh I
don't call it a cleaner because it comes
from the same word where we get inclined
right where something is off at an angle
right like inclination okay because this
is about measuring angles and
inclination okay actually they're about
measuring angles on intuition anyways I
digress
um I suppose you can call a clinometer
or a clinometer I don't know it's up to
you man so you use this to measure an
angle now you can see there's a there's
a little trigger here right there's a
little blue trigger when you hold that
down what happens is this arrow in here
it gets releases it goes loose okay once
you let it go it snaps in place and it
snaps in place on an angle you can
actually see there's those what is it
embossed or standing up you can read
that okay so let me show you how you
actually use it so step one step one
right so much I do want you to get this
down sir any hairpin here okay step one
up you hold down the trigger okay that's
the first thing you do if you want to
start measuring you hold down the
trigger and then you see this thing it
goes loose and releases right okay the
next thing you do is and for this in a
second you're gonna have to pick this up
and have a look at it you need to point
it at the top of whatever you're
measuring right so point it people have
done this to trees but you can do with
whatever you like so for instance here
is um you know here's a here's a
basketball for you okay right so this is
here's you standing the bottom and
there's the basketball hoop okay so you
want to point up towards it like that
that make sense now um you've held down
that think so this thing is waving
around as you point up and down okay now
here's the important thing to align it
now look carefully add it right um you
can see there's like there's an arrow
point here on the front overdone part of
it and then on the end there's a sort of
dip so it looks like this
a purr at the end and then closer to you
there's a part like that okay does that
make sense now when you're pointing you
want the top and the bottom to line up
right so you want to look kind of like
this it's going to have a actually this
one's in front so there's going to be
this poking out and you actually want it
to line up exactly that's how you know
you'll be out here okay so you want to
line up the arrows that's how you get
precise okay I'm at the arrow soon
there's the pointing up arrow and then
there's the pointing down alright so you
want them to line up in your line of
vision okay once you've lined them up
you can release the trigger okay so you
can look at its side on from me so
suppose I point up like that my triggers
like that
so if wait so it's still and then you
release and now you've got the angle
there okay so the last step is read off
the angle okay so you can see by the way
up zero-zero is down here down near the
bottom so it goes up like that
okay so for example it was v-0 and 10
you're going to be 5 some people think
all accounts this way just read the
unit's carefully okay and here's what
you're going to do maybe you do want to
go and do all these people on course you
can different outside actually we're
going to take two measurements okay
first you're going to go through this
and that's going to give you this angle
in here in fact I'd really like you to
draw this rough diagram so you can see
what's going on I'm going to call this
feed up okay so with the clinometer
you're going to measure theta quite
pointedly you might notice it's from
your hair or more specifically from your
eye it's not from the ground that's
actually significant the other
measurement you will need is so whatever
object you're measuring the height of
okay you want to draw a line down from
that directly to the ground so this
should be vertical and then you want to
measure the distance from you to that
spot on the ground okay from you to
that's one minute let's call that X
meters so here's what you're going to do
you're going to pick an object you
measure its angle and from that spot
where you're standing you want to
measure that distance as well okay now
hopefully you can see you know you can
get a whole bunch of these for the same
object for instance if you stand close
on all right so let's put another person
in you if you stand closer and there's
another person they're measuring their
angle is going to be higher can you see
that that angle is higher than this
angle right and in the same way this
horizontal distance will be different
same object but a different angle and a
different length or in the same way i
can stand further away the angle would
be lower and this distance would be
longer you get the idea in fact part of
what I'd like us to do is maybe either
you can do this on your own
or you can get you incorporated with a
few other pairs I want us to get as many
of these kinds of measurements as we can
same object but lots of different angles
and lengths okay